what's up everybody it's me jayden my
album is out
tell me about tomorrow and if you
haven't listened to it you're tripping
but i'm here with buzzfeed and i'm going
to be reading
thirst tweets
[Music]
there could be a really cute guy who's
into me but if he ain't jaden hustler
jaden i don't want him you say that now
but then i get into these situations and
everyone's like oh he shouldn't be like
whatever
you know so that one's like a good start
a little sweet comment girls don't want
a boyfriend they want a jayden
it's me i'm girls i don't know do you
want me as your boyfriend or do you just
want me
i don't really like see people wanting
to date me i always see people wanting
to like
be with like vinnie hacker i'm like on
the lower
stand of the totem pole but it makes me
feel special so um probably no one cares
but i'm in the hospital right now
and i don't know if that's serious but i
have this very strong pain in my chest
they told me it could be my heart due to
all the love i have for jaden
i was like genuinely concerned at first
that's sweet that would be my luck
though like someone loves me so much
they get sent to the hospital and i get
canceled
hi could y'all stop posting about jaden
i [ __ ] myself with him and
when i found your accounts i literally
started crying please do me a favor and
either private yourself or stop posting
about jaden please
you are being insensitive i feel like he
is cheating on me so please
this is one thing i never really
understood i didn't really have many
idols when i
grew up i never had like that attachment
to somebody but that's a real thing like
there's a lot of people that don't even
know me
and uh they would die for me that's a
crazy feeling jayden is hot and cute at
the same time like he has black hair
tattoos and he has blue eyes yeah i mean
i really did get blessed with blue eyes
there was a time in my life where i
thought
i would look really cool if i had black
hair with blue eyes so i did that i felt
like i looked like
danny phantom or something like like a
superhero but uh
i didn't look like anything except for a
kid that dyed his hair black with
box dye imagine if jaden body pillows
existed
that's not a bad idea would i own one if
it gives the
accurate feeling of comfort as i do then
yeah of course i would own one i would
love to get a hug for myself
i give great hugs i'm not gonna lie i
think that's like my
only talent jaden i hate you for being
so talented and hot
stop it this is like obviously
rhetorical
wait is that the word no yeah no yeah
whatever we'll go with it
i'm a [ __ ] for jaden's black hair that
has a nice ring to it you know what i
mean
that's a good tweet i know i just went
blonde i guess looking kind of yellow i
don't know i was gonna
dye it pink i'm really bad with like the
upkeep you know so
we'll see what happens maybe i'll shave
it and then that's when everyone
unfollows me jaden be gay for me
challenge
i would rock that i'm like just really
good at adapting anywhere it's 2021 baby
jaden could run me over with the truck
drag me through a bush backwards and i
would thank him after
some of you might be serious about this
like i really think someone might let me
do that jaden could rail me any day
that's just a great compliment you know
what i mean like that's just like a
straight up
no sugar coating it's like a good tweet
jaden making my
throb he's sexy when he mad people do
seem to think i get mad a lot or maybe i
just give out a lot
but that's a good spin on like an issue
a lot of people say i have
i'm glad i'm making your throb jayden if
you see this i am desperately begging
for you
that's great that you're bold enough to
say that that means i'm doing something
right i want jaden to [ __ ] me in the ass
while singing angels and demons
[ __ ] me like a rock star shouldn't you
be singing that if i was
kicking you in the ass could all the
poetics i want jaden to [ __ ] me
romney what does that even mean choke me
tell me that i'm lucky i get to take his
make me beg and scream and pull my hair
out of my head i want him to give me
chlamydia
you had me in the first half you had me
in the first step i'm not gonna lie
i want him to give me chlamydia so i can
remember that night forever
i'm not even gonna lie that i don't
actually shock me because i was in a
groove for a minute i
appreciate the request it seems like
it's coming from a good place
it's not something i plan to do or will
ever do thank you so much for the
support i love you guys
and i love your [ __ ] up minds it's not
all the time you get to hear somebody
say
[ __ ] me raw me run me over with the
truck this guy made me feel special
not gonna lie go listen to the album
guys if you haven't listened to it
already tell me about tomorrow it's very
it flows off the tongue you know
remember it tell your mom about it
please continue to share
just don't get chlamydia
you